hey guys welcome to mastering the
middlegame
I've got master Eric Hansen and today I
wanted to show a game of mine from a few
years ago it was at the feed a World Cup
I was in a must-win situation playing
against the Russian 2700 nuclear
physicist vladimir Malikov had lost the
first game it was a two game match this
was in Norway three years ago and yeah
so I had to this was a must-win start
out efore g5 I expected the Berlin and
or I expected my opponent to play solid
because all black needed was a draw
night I have 396 they should be thought
that's what I've almost always played
and Knight f6 so you know this isn't a
boring Berlin game nobody needs to needs
to leave yet it was it was it turned out
to be a bit exciting I didn't expect the
Berlin and at that time there were still
chances to fight a little bit so Knight
f6 I didn't want to go into the endgame
that's d3 so for anybody who plays d4
and encounters the Berlin you know you
can castle and that's the famous endgame
that Kasparov struggle against Kramnik
with there's a lot of history there it's
a it's it's pretty theoretical but black
does very well I didn't want to test my
Russian opponent in an end game just you
know some plays that I'm not the best
end game player so I want to keep pieces
on the board and keep chances so I
played d3 Bishop c5 and c3 actually the
reason why I play c3 instead of castling
here which is very normal is once again
fact fueled by the fact I did not want
to
trade pieces why so let's say I castle
actually black can play Knight d4 and
that just trades off just another bear
pieces makes it a bit simpler but I was
looking to keep as many pieces on the
board so that's already why I played
with like c3 black castles I Castle now
and rook e8 rook e8 is a really common
move especially when you have a bishop
when you have this Bishop developed and
you Castle quickly a lot of times you
may find that Bishop lacking space or
just under a little bit of pressure and
the benefit of a move like rook e8 over
a move like d6 is when you play d6 here
you're committing the bishop to going
this direction why my opponent decide to
play rook e8 which is a bit less common
is that he's like you know what maybe my
bishop is going to go all the way back
to f8 or it will go to a7 but I'm
leaving myself the option of that I I
never seen this move before in this
specific structure but it wasn't you
know conceptually hard to understand so
Rickie 8 I decided copy rook e1 rook e1
is very common in these royal Lopez
structure that we kind of have because
at some point white with a pawn on c3
upon leaving would like to play d4 and
try to challenge the center and E 4 is
going to be a problem when that happens
you four is going to is attacked by the
knight and eventually the rook when this
happened so rook e1 natural move
and Bishop f8 so you decided to put the
bishop this way this was his preparation
I there's good and bad things about it
but yeah I mean the the bishop the
bishop is gonna go to f8 before playing
d6 or maybe d5 so after Bishop at fate I
wasn't sure if block was wanting to play
d6 or d5 and I was looking at I was
looking at a bunch of options but I was
thinking to myself I was thinking to
myself I don't know this opening too
well and maybe he's prepared for the
standard moves and for those who have
studied Spanish structures a standard
move might here might be knight Knight
d2 net f1 and Knight g3 that's a really
common way to get that Knight into the
game because I already played c3 my
knight can't go to c3 so I want to get
my knight so that's just a really that'd
be a really common sequence or h3 or
something like that now just like I can
do this but I feel like maybe seeing if
something else can be done in this
position I don't want to just rely on I
feel like if I just buy the generic most
non my opponent maybe has something in
store for that so I decided to force the
issue after Bishop f8 and play d4
because usually black does play d6 here
d6 was normally played the bishop does
not normally go to f8 and one benefit
for white of the bishop going at fate is
that d4 you know is under law I can get
d4 a lot easier
there's no bishop on that square so I
play d4 ok this is still in the opening
phase although I have no idea like I'm
not in theory after in this case you
know there's a few different options
here for black you can try to play d6
and not give up the center
there's a six here as well I was
considering a six now a six just
plunders upon you can't play a six a six
to attacked a bit you know the pawn the
pawn is hanging so d6 d6 was the only
move besides taking here I mean the I
the idea I had I wanted to make the
position pretty sharp was after it takes
d4 it might look like this pawn is
hanging so for example of pawn takes d4
you know Knight takes Knight takes e4
that's just simple matters to pieces
attacking me for yes so my opponent did
he takes d4 here pretty logical but now
things get very sharp I have to play e5
that's the whole plan behind this move
is my pawn is hanging so I'm going to
first play e5 make sure it's no longer
hanging and then I'm going to recapture
on d4 so after E 5 one thing as my
opponent took a lot of time here so
we're pretty much you know out of theory
and it was going to be a sharp position
after E 5 Knight d5 you don't really
want to put the night anywhere else
h5 is a bad square g4 drops it g4
they're all pretty shaky but at least on
d5
where my block put it makes a lot of
sense because it can always go to b6
let's see it has a safe square whereas
the other squares don't really have a
safe square after Knight d5 I was
which is what I expected I took a bit of
a thing here I have the option of just
taking the pawn back and this position
looks pretty nice for white I mean how
the pawn center a lot of space seemingly
maybe this Bishop is coming to g5 a lot
of easy development but I I wasn't sure
about this
after d6 I wanted you know after d6
let's say Bishop g5 Queen d7 I thought
this was a good position but because it
was a must-win game I was like
doublethink you know I was double
checking every single move and trying to
be really precise one thing is my
opponent was 2,700 and I was rated
around 2600 at the time but I'd never
beaten a super grandmaster so it was a
must-win game against the caliber of
player I'd never really played against
in fact so I was like really really
nervous and it was also around this
position that the former world champion
kramnik came to my game it's a bit of a
funny story he's the guy who used this
opening to defeat Kasparov so he every
time he's interested in looking at games
that have the opening that he pretty
much got into popularity and we were
writing the game I was reading you know
use a score sheet to record your moves
and you know I had never met this was my
first one my first turn big tournaments
hold it so I never met a lot of these
players and I wasn't meeting them during
the game but kramnik was there he's a
really big guy he comes to my game I
have my paper beside me and my pen
because you're supposed to write he
takes my pen he moves it away so that he
can read my score sheet but he like
takes my pen and like moves my paper and
pretty much grabs my score sheet bring
my book and if Kramnik does that I mean
for all I I was I was I was just I
didn't know I didn't say anything I mean
the world heals former world champion is
the best player in this opening he
hadn't seen this type of position before
it was somehow interesting to him and he
just decided to go you know do do it
he's allowed to do what he wants I
figured that I was like some sort of you
know I'm not going to really say no I'm
like an ant compared to him so that at
this at this moment I started like if
he's looking at the game maybe there's
also some more possibilities for me or
maybe like it's interesting I mean so I
was like okay maybe maybe there's some
different moves here that aren't aren't
available so I was I was thinking here I
was like okay I can obviously capture
the pawn but maybe I have something a
little bit better and I started looking
at this idea I was looking at the idea
of Bishop c4 because I know black wants
to play d6 next move and get that Bishop
out and attack my center so I was
looking at I started looking at moves
like Bishop c4 and I started having
ideas like Knight b6 maybe maybe you
know Bishop to f7 king of seven Knight
g5 check I started looking at this
combination let's say King g8 and Queen
b3 it came to my mind at least I felt
like okay blacks Bishop is out of the
game this Bishop right now is not yet in
the game so here what I was thinking
would actually work but there was a move
like rookie six rookie six and you know
96 and black has two pieces for the rook
and his King is safe but once I saw that
idea I started thinking a bit more and
more because it's at least it's
reasonable I realized okay I can
recapture the pawn either way but maybe
I have a better move first and it that
led me to think about Queen b3 so I
ended up going for Queen b3 first the
benefit of Queen b3 is that after Knight
b6 I don't have a bishop being attacked
on c4
so queen bee three I wanted to win you
know one sometime
so queen bee three black only has one
move here really I mean if you're going
to play some move like Knight dt7
you're going to have a very bad time
after Knight g5 so we see situations
though when blacks lack of development
is pretty you know pretty bad so Knight
b6
and after 96 I took back on d4 and d5
anyways after d5 d5 is a good move
because black blacks gaining a lot more
space than playing d6 if you can play d5
over d6 you normally do that
d5 blocks the diagonal you know of my
queen develops the bishop and of course
I'm not going to consider this move
again because I'm leaving myself with an
isolated pawn not only that but there's
tactics like net rook e1 Jack Knight
takes u 1 and Knight takes t4 did you
have a question oh no okay and Knight
takes d4 so it gets messy but I can't be
happy to be you know I don't want to go
into any sort of complications when I
have all these pieces of undeveloped so
C takes d4 d5
so I have to develop if you can develop
with temple next move this should be v
pretty self-explanatory I want to
develop my bishop and that move is is a
bit of attractive because okay f6 is not
really desirable so Queen d7 and the
most natural move here would just be
what I'm saying just develop the pieces
don't need to think too much about it
probably Knight c3 or 92-93 h6 maybe
Bishop f4 but White has a little bit of
a space advantage based on the pawns we
have two pawns in the center pushed into
blacks position and black still has to
figure out how to unravel note my rook
is on e one so and in the case of let's
say Knight c3 and in the case of a6 am I
going to take on c6 or am I going to
play like Bishop the
through your Bishop f1 I'm going to
trade off the bishop for on c6 or am I
going to retreat it I'm going to retreat
I'm not going to give me the bishop pair
for you know without some serious
compensation and I have this f1 square
as well I might so I just had to go for
rook c1 and as I said I was overthinking
a little bit in this game but that's
because of the situation I'd never been
in a match well yeah I'm not used to
playing matches to gain matches where I
had to win in the second game so I was
really trying to be super precise and
rook c1 and the only idea of rook c1 is
pretty clear I want to take on c6 and
double those bonds so I was looking for
positional imbalance no matter what and
now black pretty much has no way of
stopping me from taking on c6 and
doubling the pawns a6 okay they should
take c6 b takes c6 and now now we have
the real imbalance in the position now
giving up the bishop pair I have a
structural structural edge it's a pretty
dynamic position so 90 to 190 to 93
blocks the open file I'd rather put my
knight on d2 coordinated my Knights and
use that C file so that black can play
c5 and undal the C pawns when you have
two bishops you want to open up the
position as white here I'm trying to
play against this fix it there keep
black passive and reduced to defending
that double pawn black plays a5 maybe
opening up a six for the bishop because
once again I mean the Queen does not the
queen is kind of stuck here I move like
h6 doesn't really change much I'm just
going to play Bishop h4 and you're not
really going to play a g5 and at the
same time you also don't want to trade
off bishops as as black probably like
black could play this to try to stop my
bishop from being such a pain but if we
try to have the dogs for bishops just an
example
you know I can just play moves like rook
c5 I have full control over the dark
squares that definitely does not look
like black will be able to undo those
pawns
so after Knight d2 d2
a5 maybe that Bishop will go to be seven
or a six maybe it helps get the bishop
there but black needs to open up the
position and an a6 has some a a five
could potentially do that what move can
white play to kind of you know keep that
Bishop on c8 pretty passive otherwise
keeping the bishops passive Queen c2 but
my queen did its job on b3 so just Queen
back to c2 and you know running to win
the pawn on c6 the Queen's not really on
sure footing on b3 anyways at some point
a for rook b8 there's a few moves Queen
c2 is pretty safe maybe and Bishop yeah
so now black play Bishop e7 rookie six
as always it is it is possible but it's
not it's not the most human move
sometimes yeah it's not it's it really
depends but rookie six could have been
possible but there's a bit of a clumsy
setup there it was possible though they
should be seven and I didn't know why
play Bishop d7 I thought he's gonna play
rook e6 and in this position I decided
in this position to play a four and a 93
was an alternative I could have gone for
my idea behind 84 was just too fixed
upon on a5 for some future end games and
to just yeah just to fix up on because
it that is an isolated pawn I thought I
thought it would be maybe a weakness in
the future I didn't think this Bishop
would stay there forever so
in the future I might also have ideas of
Knight B 3 and Bishop d2 and going for
that maybe you can play Knight B 3 night
f - D - I don't know as long the thing
is in this game I just want to make sure
not all the pieces be trade off or we
just have tension all the time or
potential and in this position it's not
being resolved any time soon so I was
just happy happy about that as long as
things weren't being traded off a lot so
a for fixing up on on a5 and in my
opponent plays 94 and I'll be honest I
didn't really consider that move I mean
it didn't I didn't put much thought into
nights before he played 94 like right
away and I was down already 40 minutes
on the clock because I was a I was just
I was thinking every single move trying
to be pretty precise around this part of
the game I realized I need to play
faster otherwise I'm just going to get
in time trouble I can't keep taking this
much time but he plays 94 right away
this is a pretty critical moment with
anybody tempted to take on c4 your temp
that is you know there's pawn
there's pond robbers out of ten people
there's always going to be a few pong
drivers so I has to be looked at oh why
is it Knight takes e4 very attractive
though so how would that go so let's say
Knight c4 queen tech c4
pawn up and I mean he played the move
instantly so here evaluate this is just
very good and it's pretty right if I
take two pawns I'm not very happy with
my King position here for the price of
one pawn and not not too happy with my
my position here yeah I know I know I
know I know that's why I was curious
well I mean black black just opens up
the position entirely there's a few
other moves too but this is this is
compensation this is a pretty
substantial positional compensation King
safety so I decided intuitively just to
keep the pieces on the board and play
Knight f1 and then play b3 anyways and
the benefit is we haven't traded off a
pair of pieces the knight presumably has
to just go back to b6
where I don't think it was doing a great
job so I decide okay I mean I can play
b3 next move you can't play c5 right now
because b3 and that Knight doesn't have
anywhere to go back to c5 I take them on
I'm going to win a piece with C takes b6
or c6 next move
end up I duped I liked I liked what I
did here black has no way of stopping v3
I want Queen e6 because it feels like
black is playing pretty slowly still has
this issue of the bishop on b7 two
bishops are good when they're active
these are not too active bishops they're
not bad bishops entirely but they're not
active white I feel like most people
would probably prefer White's position
here black is looking ahead b3 can't be
stopped
so with Queen e6 so that's a bit of you
know strategical planning who wants to
play anticipating after b3 the knight is
going to drop to d7 from to b6 to d7
because the night on b6 is does not have
any scope so b3 I have to play b3
anyways then Knight b6 the bishop can
draw it back to d2 and put long term
pressure on a five so now Knight g3 by
97 and this is a very good regrouping
because I mean after Queen e6 I didn't
really see a way for me to stop black
from playing Knight b6 97 I mean there's
no way to stop that III Knight b6 Knight
g3 97 so just regrouping and trying to
play for c5 yes
Bishop e3 I mean I I put my work on see
when I put so much effort into stopping
c5 okay my bishop here did its job
earlier back to e3 also frees up g5 for
my knight in some variations Bishop e3 I
was feeling pretty good after Bishop e3
and then he plays c5 instantly what can
you do
c5 is correct I mean this is how you
play with the two bishops it doesn't
stop it stops c5 in the way that I can
take it but if I take on c5 what does
that allow black to do
take the e pawn just take the e pawn and
that's a trade one for one and that's
only going to benefit black opening up
the position getting rid of White's bind
white senator control that would erode a
lot of my a lot of my positional edge so
c5 but at this point I can't stop it 92
was another move I was considering but I
went for Queen see throughout thought
it's the same idea as 92 the idea is is
black were to take on d4 I'm going to
take with my knight so black gets rid of
the double pawns let's say Queen takes
e5 I have Queen takes c7 here attacking
the knight on d7 the bishop on b7 so
Queen takes let's say Queen takes e5
rook takes e5 Bishop c8 I mean there
aren't really any and and white spot
what's better
I mean White's better isolate upon an a5
isolate upon on d5 even though there's
two bishops that's two weaknesses I'd be
happy that that would be a favorable
trade I mean I have two weaknesses black
has some competition but White's better
there with that pawn structure and the
fact that I have a pretty good C file
here you know Rock a c1 it looks
unpleasant for black and that's
important because he takes d4 it forces
block because I'm attacking the Queen
and attacking c7 so you don't really
have a way to to get rid of it you want
c6 didn't want to go for that variation
after c6 though I had an idea I'm happy
to see c6 so that means that Bishop on
b7 is not going to be a monster
like it wasn't some lines but now I'm
forced to trade on c5 because no matter
what black is going to be taking on d4
and E 5 will be critically weak then
black will have all the pressure on e5
so D take c5 96 d5 Knight takes e5 I
didn't have to trade but I thought
Bishop d4 and my knight and Bishop are
better than blacks two bishops I thought
the bishop was really well placed on d4
centralized I'm going to bring my rooks
to e1 the only file and black has this
problem with a bishop on b7 still its
Queen g5 rook e1 I kind of have to trade
rooks here just a fight for the file my
knight on g3 doesn't really have a
better square otherwise I would probably
try to improve that maybe maybe I could
consider mother Queen f3 but why why
rook e1 first before a move like Queen
f3 for example why rook e1 played rookie
one first because you know maybe I have
to remove the Queen f3 five black I'm
looking at moves like Bishop to c8 now
that the bishops not doing anything on
b7 and rerouting that Bishop maybe to G
for a better diagonal that's just not
doing anything on b7
by going Ricky one you obviously can't
go bishop CA now and if you trade rooks
and go Bishop c8 I can play rook e8 so
it's not not quite the same
interestingly enough my opponent is a
player I grew up studying so I kind of
the position I went for is white what
was telling me to go for this position
is maybe studying this guy's game so he
was quite maybe it wasn't coincidence
but he was pretty uncomfortable in this
position and getting into time trouble
and has it like it was I was playing one
of my favorite players so I was kind of
maybe using stuff I learned against them
but I thought white has a pretty
Pleasant advantage here and and this a
five pawn is pretty weak in end games if
you picture all the pieces off of the
board at some point black I mean white
can try to if c5 is covered go for a
five and that will be an outside passed
pawn there's some that isolate upon
could be a liability so it's I thought I
had two endgame edge here as well h5 was
played to play h4 bishop see not
possible not rook e1 because I just
gives away the e-file but I mean Bishop
a6
that's it should be six what are we
doing as white all the pawn robbers
stand up what are we doing here we can
actually just take this you can put your
Bishop anywhere you want on the board
anywhere you want I'm just going to put
my Queen back to c3 there that I have no
pieces on the light squares so that
discovered attack is nothing so Bishop
e6 not possible black black plays h5
although if you're a pawn grabber after
age five what can you do you can do a
rook takes you one rook - sorry rook
takes rook takes e8 Queen takes a five
didn't really go for this I'm not I
enjoyed having control over the position
and I wasn't a big fan of the
complications that arise after putting
my knight to f1 and something like h3 I
don't want to lose the game because I
went for that pawn on on the a file
black is getting quite a bit of counter
play here we file mating threats wasn't
my cup of tea
so after rook e1 age five
okay we're both getting a bit of time
trouble I don't want to trade on anyone
I saw it on yet
I like black citrate I want to get the
file completely yeah h3h3 is what I
played and there's two reasons for that
one of you know one of them might be
that I want to take that pawn in a
variation another one is similar to what
black did earlier in the game the key
key theme is a knight regrouping
so I played h3 you don't play h5 to just
keep the pawn on h5 usually black plays
h4 probably could have played well I
move like g6 a waiting move maybe was a
bit worried about weakening the dark
squares fair enough
there were some better moves but my
opponent was not comfortable in this
position it does play h4 I play net f1
but it comes to my mind immediately that
you know that night I'm not going to put
my knight on III that's blocking the
e-file but I can get the knight to f3
that's an improvement over g3 at least
it has a target and black is starting to
run out of moves though for example
white is threatening to take on EA tand
take on a5 getting a connect sorry I
passed pawn so black decides to go rook
takes e1 finally concedes rook takes see
one Bishop c8 how's that you know just
going to keep improving my position
Knight h2 what's nice about the Queen on
c3 is it attacks a 5 and it attacks g7
it's a pretty well placed I mean it does
it does it i the e-file I have a nice
diagonal along here and the rook is
offside whereas the Queen is not really
offside at least it keeps black honest
on the Kings side with the Queen so
protecting a lot of squares Bishop d7
and keep in mind it was like Bishop e7
run into some tactics such as Bishop
takes g7 pieces are you know dis
coordinated and rook takes e7 now you
can do Bishop c5 but you're giving up
the back rank shouldn't be shouldn't be
after Bishop c5 rook e8 check there's
going to be some danger black plays
Bishop d7 I'm not going to give up yet
Knight f3 Queen to h6 Queen h5 was also
playable okay quick go back to d8 but
black now has two weaknesses or to kind
of loose pawns b3 is a bit weak for
white but White's pieces are a little
bit better so at this at this position I
mean I'm playing like in my opinion I
felt like I was playing the best game in
my life at this stage it was a must-win
and I'm like putting a 2700 under
serious pressure I mean it's definitely
a good position for white with the
e-file and like my pieces are in good
squares it can't be bad so I was like I
was getting quite confident here the is
getting on time trouble
he plays Queen h6
and put 95 I was I wasn't sure if I
should be going for be for because one
thing is after be for that I get a
passed pawn but it's a little loose but
the benefit of this is I I started
having with the Queen offside on h6
maybe I can quickly get a queen b7 in or
something I start having some tactical
threats so this was an alternative the
nice thing is this bishop is not a big
factor in the game Bishop on d4 nicely
keeps it keeps it passive so b4 was it
Oh an option but okay in time trouble I
don't need to force it I can try to wait
for black to blunder Black has many ways
to blunder keep in mind if black loses
that e5 pawn it should be a losing
endgame protected passed pawns protected
outside passed pawns that that's that's
not just a pawn that's a you know that's
a really important like those are those
are very hard to defend you don't you
can't use your King you have to tie a
piece down so based on this I'm like
okay why is white better
I think White's better because my work
is better that's what I was thinking
because the rook on its passive so I was
trying to figure out a way to get my
rook into the game but first I don't
really see a nice entry square I can
move my rook here work to g5 it's not
entirely clear
felt like a zombie Center and I should
bring in my knight to join the party
95 it's nice that my rook on a once
protected there's no moves like rookie
yet this should be a and I'm like
starting to get that feeling you know
that feeling when there's tactics
there's stuff going on I mean the
bishops are fine when they were played
back like that but like oh this this
doesn't look good I mean it really feels
like white is improving the position
starting to get really excited here well
I don't as I said earlier I don't want
what my rook on you won blocked by that
night that wasn't my plan after Bishop
e8 that freeze open to square Knight to
g4 attacking the Queen keeping the file
open Queen to f4 there aren't too many
moves here obviously the Queen can't you
know Queen asked to stay probably on a
light square but the position was so
enjoyable because like I don't know
Queen Queen g6 okay quick there are
moves you can play as okay ah after a
move like Queen g6 I was seeing in my
head funny moves that never normally
happen I was even thinking oh I can play
like Bishop moves like Bishop f6 that
was like coming into my mind I mean I'm
starting to get that you know like
Glen's like black is look at black is
too passive moves like Bishop f6 that
look kind of outrageous start looking a
bit more reasonable for those wondering
why Knight takes f6 the King has to move
and I take the piece discovered check
there are defenses there but the fact
that I can play move like this and be
okay it's not a losing move like white
can play this move and be okay I was
like I mean that can't be bad if I can
just leave pieces hanging so but I was
so calm play rook
I played rookie 5 I'm sorry but Queen f4
and a new queen I for was a mistake
going into the game because I plan to
bring my rook in I had planned to bring
my work into the game and queen up for I
was very happy to respond with rookie
five the Queen cannot go back to the
safe area anymore
and in this position the Queen has no
squares so after the Queen out for Ricki
five the Queen's aren't trapped because
I'm not attacking it right now but it
actually does not have any squares I am
actually threatening g3 I think right so
I thought this was Queen afore was a
blunder we're both like under 10 minutes
I play rook e5 and I start feeling like
I'm going to when g3 wins the Queen and
that's not a bit it's not a very common
configuration to trap the Queen like
this so I like yeah Queen Queen h5 was
better okay Queen h5 not ideal because
of a move like rookie 5 so Queen g6 was
supposed to be played probably Queen f4i
I just dish out rook rook here and I
move like f6 just g3 just going to
ignore that and game over this would be
a really nice game if I was to win like
that I would just you know I started
getting ahead of myself sort of getting
thoughts like that he plays the only
move but I anticipate is plays the only
move f5y f5 because I'm not threatening
to take the knight if I play g3 it
shields the Queen to go to g5 okay use
2700 is going to find he's not going to
let his Queen get trapped I had to wake
up to reality there he's not gonna get
his Queen traps I think in Russia you
might get sent you know to a prison or
something of that if you get your Queen
trapped by Canadian chess player that
would be
that would be pretty bad so you know f5
and I got really excited here and I was
thinking I was thinking I I just got
really excited here and played something
really quickly you know what I just got
a little bit impulsive tonight and I
thought I saw a win what win or what win
did I can anybody guess what I thought I
liked the ghosts I was seen after f5
why Bishop III why am I happy about
Bishop III I didn't think I worked I
didn't know why you like I didn't know
if I was possible so when he played it I
replied instantly why was I happy with
Bishop III I thought I was winning the
pawn on f5 after Bishop III I thought
the Queen has to move to b4 i take on b4
I take on f5 and I'm threatening to play
rook out for and just like take
everything like rook a five rook F for
let's say Bishop c5 Bishop c5 White's up
a pawn this pawn is very weak outside
passed pawn blacks Bishop is that this
is a very very good endgame for black
out for white rook air-five this is much
much better for white that's that's
that's a pawn there's compensation
because you can draw work any games can
be drawn you know how it is whatever but
White's in a position of strength here
that is a pawn
plays d4 right away
you know they always tell you when
you're calculating or something you look
at for signals d4 would be the only
other like move the only other bone to
throw there's no other way to attack me
like these pieces you guys know you only
has a pawn in a queen near me so but I
play Bishop III like instantly like I
was getting excited and I played quickly
d 4 d 4 is a pretty good move to find
with a little time but it's going to
find that y is d4 so good well first of
all by do Queen takes d4 Queen takes I
have a piece hanging the bishop takes
piece hanging but why D for might look
intuitively where that first is white
has a check and the queen is hanging but
he had worked out this already but after
d4 I have to go into it and that's where
things go badly because throughout the
game there is never a clear forcing
variation there's always possibilities
there weren't mass trades ever available
after d4 I have to go for it because I
have to I can't take on d4 have to play
Queen c4 check Bishop f7 and now there's
two different moves I can take the Queen
this should take trade off Queens black
takes the knight I'm up a pawn here but
these are the ugliest pawns in the world
I I'm not I don't think I'm beating a
Russian Grand Master in this but it's
actually not good at you plays rook b8
he's getting that rook to b4 and all of
a sudden I'm not sure who's better
because I was going to get probably both
of those pawns rookie six I don't this
isn't winning endgame rook b8 you know
rookie six
even throwing maybe even a check but I
think mass trades happen something like
this it should do I'm not going to be up
a clear pawn though like any other
variation even this is not a nice fun
yeah I went for the cleaner version of
this that's Queen takes f7 so I don't
have doubled see pawns King takes f7
Bishop takes Queen pawn takes pawn pawn
takes pawn so now I'm up I'm up a pawn
and I hope nobody you know he can't play
rook b8 here cannot play rook b8 because
I've looked at five check otherwise
Rypien would be a good move hitting b3
but he had seen this position and just
coolly played g6 and I'm up a pawn here
and I've absolutely zero winning chances
and that's that's very impressive wow
that's impressive that you'd calculate
all this because it looks like a clean
pawn and then g6 but that D pawn is so
strong and now rook b8 is coming c5 is a
target I have to keep my rook on e5
because c5 is weak but I can't do
anything with my rock on u5 black is
going to play rook b8 or push the D pawn
I just I can't stay with my rook on e5
it's blocking my bishop you know like a
move like Bishop d2 rook b8 these trades
not so good this endgame so I'll show
how went that was in the critical point
King f1 bring my king in
rook a7 nicely played
because it worked be it now I still had
ideas maybe I can go for this endgame
like maybe maybe it's a little bit
better for why I just thought maybe but
he just played work 87 not even allowing
a chance the rook goes to be 7 next move
and so this we get into any game where I
am up upon I'll just show how that
happens I didn't really have a way here
it should be six d3 rookie one I offer
to draw
I know winning chances I'll show why
let's say rookie one rack a 3/8 I have
to pretty much play rook t1 if I play
something like a5 my bishops entombed
and have to remove like Bishop h6 d 2
and I'm really passive that King is
going to walk in into the game and even
though I'm up upon it's not showing in
the position at all the d3 pawn is much
stronger so rook e1
and there is material equality the
critical point that I had when I should
not have rushed a move I had 10 minutes
on the clock and black was playing only
moves was by the way even if I had a
losing position I might have gone to
draw because you're allowed I don't for
anybody in match situations that the
person can there's like a common thing
where you can even get a draw from the
lost position because they just want to
win the match so but like this was
actually just a draw but I didn't travel
from Canada to Norway for that so I
didn't want to win and the one chance I
had was after f5
I should have obviously taken my time
that's still an issue for me I'm very
impulsive but 93 just keeping the pieces
on the board calmly playing 93 attacking
f5 is really strong and I saw 93
I saw 93 and I saw that it was really
good I just thought I was winning a
clean pot in the other variation I just
thought I was winning a clean pot so
it's like a good move or a clean bond
it's like they both seemed pretty
attractive because here I was looking at
Bishop d7 so 93 hitting g6 you have to
defend g6 say Bishop d7 I saw Knight see
494 is kind of tricky
why 94 because of pawn takes Knight c4
Bishop e3 traps the Queen and in the
middle of the board again and I have
Knight a5 Knight b6 the bishop on f8 is
still bad that bishop on d4 is really
good g6 was a little more worrisome but
that's what I was expecting
I rook takes d5 and this is a bit harder
to see this is harder to see in time
trouble although those watching the
candidates matches saw yesterday
somebody pull off a pretty impressive
combination in time trouble so it's
definitely doable rook takes d5 the
thing is I was looking for tactics rook
takes d5 C takes d5 Knight takes d5
Queen has to go to b8 here or yeah has
to go to b8 for the most part can't go
to e4 because in Knight f6 let's just
say Queen B just to show a variation
Knight f6 King out 7 if you put the King
on a dark square I take on the a let's
check Queen C for check King g7 and
there's a combination here after c6 ok
it's there's there's a losing variation
for black here and I I'm not sure I
would have seen all of it and I don't
blame myself for not seeing all of it
but though the whole point is I let my
opponent get into that game and 93 is
good even if I don't find that because
it keeps the pieces on the board and
keeps the tension
it keeps the possibility so even though
don't find a winning the best move after
g6 even if I don't find this this crazy
variation with Queen C for the King
walks I play check even if I don't find
that I don't go into an endgame so we
can both blender but what I went into
was an endgame that my opponent just
understood immediately I'm down upon but
it's a draw the Queen's were off with
the Queen's Own there's all sorts of
possibilities and he might not even
played g6 might have played Bishop d7
and immediately after 94 you know whites
doing really really well
with Bishop to e3 so that was my one
shot but and then then I just by quick
Bishop e3 and you saw what happened it
was a draw fairly fairly quickly and I
had no chance afterwards it was just all
forcing but I thought it was you know it
was the first time I'd outplayed a
strong player in the middle game and we
had all the
the entire game was that battle battle
in the C file and on a5 and it looked
like I wanted so I thought was a pretty
interesting game definitely a setback
but but really enjoyable is one of my I
was happy with the effort at least so
that was a game I want to share from
Norway a few years ago I ended up
drawing the game so still technically a
good result but I lost the match